[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum you saw ryan
just sitting down that's my thing now i
gotta catch you sitting down
three times in a row now it's uh yeah
well
authentic just to make sure it's like
hey we're just we're just going here
we're not
this isn't scripted yeah hey everyone
how are you today
hello hey guys thanks for listening um i
i will say this because it's important
and i was told to say it because it is
important
but please if you're enjoying the show
it really helps
i mean the show is free right unless
you're an awesome patron and
you're contributing more which is
unbelievable but
uh if you could write a review on apple
podcasts
that's huge it's an algorithm thing
so write a review go to apple podcast
right now press pause just
write a review real quick hopefully five
stars if you if you like it
um and if you're here for tom welling
and then you you know usually the
numbers grow
jump up big but stick around we've got a
lot of great guests and if you like this
hey do your old
uh rosenbaum lex luthor favor here stick
around man we were just in
screen rant a few days ago actors with
podcasts we were ranked number five so
it was like dax's podcast and i think
sophia bush mine uh
oliver hudson and kate hudson they have
a show so we were five that
that made me really happy yeah i mean
you know you shouldn't engage happiness
based on
you know uh we've talked about this in
the show but it's it's nice to see that
you're getting
acknowledgement is not a bad thing five
out of ten is pretty solid
it's my average in school what now dax
what now
what up daddy dax [ __ ] i love you
he won't watch this ever he's never seen
it he's never heard it where he won't
it's fine
i've listened to his when you have three
hours to kill yeah i won't listen to
three hours
my that's why mine's an hour so people
can go on my way to work and then on
their way home from work they could
finish it
with with other shows like joe rogan
it's like so i'm gonna start this on
monday and i'll end by february jesus
yeah i can't do it i i love those guys
great shows i i assume they're huge
um i just can't i can't talk that long
and i just i'm like
as whoa as uninteresting or interesting
as i could be or am sometimes which i
don't believe i
am i get uninteresting really fast if i
get tired i'm like oh god i got 80d ah
look at that oh i have a lost boys
poster yeah dude you've had it forever
while you're looking at it cause i'm
bored that's why you're number five man
i'm number five and i'm not number one
uh if ethan's listening he's going ah
ryan with a zinger 2021 zinger
but uh go to apple podcast please if
you're listening there or have the app
stop what you're doing go support the
show it takes a couple of seconds it
really helps everything we're doing here
we also have a stage it rob and i my
band sunspin i know if you're tired of
hearing it wait till the album comes out
because i think you're gonna love it
um the website is up
sunspin.com and you just go on the
website
merch and you could book the band and
upcoming shows which we have one january
30th which is the
last saturday oh there's a coaster it's
a sunspin coaster
we're getting better ones too there's
those but we're getting like really cool
granite ones or stone ones
um yeah i like it though i collect
coasters i like it yeah well i guess
he's asking for one
hmm i have to remember that so uh that
uh if you want to follow us on the
sunspin handles that's at sunspit band
sunspin band on all the uh socials and
what's the inside of you handles ryan
they're at
inside of you pot on twitter
and it's uh inside of your podcast on
instagram and facebook inside you
podcast on uh instagram and facebook
youtube.com slash inside of you with
michael rosenbaum yes and and
also you can follow me on stage at stage
it.com that's where the uh the shows
uh sun spin the more followers i get
it's great because then i could just
message you and say hey we have a show
and you can be alerted
um and sunspin we could use a hell of a
lot more followers on those blow those
suckers up on the handles let's get a
big following for old sunspin here
just because i'm a little older doesn't
mean i can't have a rock band live your
dreams folks
live your dreams i'm not in it to be a
rock star i'm in it too
once beat it be ground
it beats the ground you just gotta do
what you love you gotta do what you love
also uh why don't we do this why don't
we take fifteen percent off at the end
uh inside you online store we got
tumblers new tumblers we got
hats and shirts and uh awesome coffee
mugs that are running out and we got
some uh there's some pictures lex luthor
pictures
we got lunch boxes now smallville lunch
boxes the code is
how about happy new year 21 for 15 off
happy new year 21 for 15 off everything
at the online store a big guest today
um he's tall he's like six four you guys
know him he was clark kent he was my
buddy we've become closer friends over
the years we go to conventions together
we do smallville nights whenever
conventions come you'll have to visit us
it's a
it's a great evening um and
you just edited this edit edited this
ryan and um what was your overall
feeling uh i i liked it because and this
is your third time with tom williams
third time i tried to do one every year
i
i'd never yeah so i'd never really uh
listened nope be honest yeah
you son of a [ __ ] well it was an old
one of course and now you could watch
you could listen
uh all that and you know what i love
about this is he has a secret that he
tells today
and pretty pretty early in the episode
and uh i don't think it's out so you're
gonna have to stick around it's pretty
fun
it's pretty funny also he uh he was
in africa south africa doing a show and
boy did that get bonkers
uh gunfire and [ __ ] like that but you
know he moved away
he's you know he's taking care of his
wife and the little man thompson
who i love and uh why say you know i
said wife
jess i love jess jess jess
i love you you're uh you're the meat and
potatoes you're
you're the without him without her i
think he'd be
effed without a good woman next to us
as men we're screwed if we're single
we're probably screwed really screwed
and if we have a good we don't have a
good woman next to us
we could be even more screwed in other
words you have to have a solid
foundation
yep which i don't know the answer i
don't know how to find that why don't we
just say hell with it and let's get
inside of tom welling
it's my point of view you're
listening to inside of you
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
first of all i don't know what's
happened with it you know happy new year
by the way
oh yeah happy new year yeah happy new
year bob what about that
you forgot about the new year huh well
you know i'm sure there's a lot of
people
listening or watching this that it's
tough to know what day it is
sometimes during all this it is man
it is there's really no like mondays or
fridays or saturdays i mean
i'm really happy the football came back
because at least i know what day it is
because it's football on tv
who do you root for it's one of four
days if you're watching football so
who do you root for anybody i wrote from
all
every for everybody i don't really have
a team i just like good games
um there was a game that i watched
recently
i think it was the browns and the ravens
yeah
and it was like it was like
i don't know three touchdowns and a
field goal to win the game in the last
two minutes it was like that was one of
the best games
see that's fun that's fun to watch you
know during this whole time
you know with the kova thing and all the
[ __ ] that's going on you know i had
like everybody has their bad stuff you
know my mom got covered oh i didn't know
that
yeah she got covered uh yeah she's doing
all right thank god uh it was a little
bit you know because my mom's you know
i'm i could be a
hypocrite hydrochondriac a hypochondriac
sometimes but
you know my mother it's just like
michael i'm going to get a mammogram
i've talked about that and she's like am
i okay that's what women do
i know but what if i have cancer i'm
like well they'll treat it
i don't this is you know and i'm giving
her advice and i i don't take my own
advice when i kind of like freak out
about something
like well that hasn't happened why are
you worried about something that hasn't
happened but that's a story of my life
do you do that well i mean i i think
that you know in the time that i've
known you there's
there's got to be some trickle-down
emotionality there from the mother
everything comes from the mother i mean
mothers are very important um
i see that my own life with my own child
um but
you know i i can see where what
what what are you talking about what are
you referring to i want you to analyze
me
what is it that you see that might have
as you call it trickle
down from my mother i mean i think
you're very well adjusted you're one of
the kindest person
kindest people i know um
i mean as as as add and nuts as you can
be
at times you're like the nicest person
in the world like i know some other
people who
who get all amped up in add and they're
just like rude and
you're not you're kind you're a very
kind person you're in your soul and i'm
at least you have that but the
hypochondriac
that whole thing i mean that's got to
come from your mom a little bit based on
your
story yeah i mean you know i mean i i
don't know if you have anxiety
yeah you know i have anxiety i had you
know sometimes we were at those
conventions i was having a bad time with
anxiety and uh there were a couple of
times where
we're taking pictures and sometimes
those lines are long with hundreds of
people
and i'm wondering how many we have left
i keep asking
jp your guy or whatever or you know how
many we have left because
i'm like i gotta i remember just like i
i i didn't tell you but i was i was
having bad anxiety did you notice or
i covered it no i do remember you always
being like um
okay how many laps how many left how
many left you're not in a bad way
uh but just being i didn't realize that
you were
sort of trying to sort out your own pace
um i just thought you were trying to
keep track of how many people were going
through to be honest but
um you know it's
the ups and downs that the conventions
are really
strangely amazing and i mean i only go
you know
you brought me into them and um i found
a way to really
like enjoy them and enjoy the fans and
but the flip side is you're on
like the whole time and i'm not trying
to complain anybody out there
but you want to be there for every
single person who's there for you
absolutely yeah
and it's it's a lot of energy and and at
the end of the day it's great
when you look at the lines and
everything else and you want to be there
for those people i can see where the
anxiety might creep up about how you're
going to be able to
yeah but it's not really my i don't
think my anxiety was it wasn't from the
people like i was
nervous to meet them i just go in these
waves where i'm
absolutely elated and no no anxiety and
just confident and want to make people
laugh
but there was a time period and i you
know and those scare you when you get
anxiety i don't know if you've dealt
with it but when you go through a period
of time where you're you you're in
anything triggers anxiety and you're
like am i going to be
too tired am i going to be this or am i
not going to be enough i don't know what
it was but
there was a time period where i just i
couldn't even place where it was coming
from
do you get do you you know i notice you
you get cause you're like
i'm here i'm safe i'm in a completely
safe environment
i'm in completely control of
the time and and and like the ratio of
you're in complete control yet you still
have anxiety which
that's a different anxiety i've had
anxiety when i when i realized i'm not
prepared
for a situation and then i get anxiety
maybe that's nerves what happens
to you oh you just yeah i mean there's
there's only been a couple times that
i've that i
feel like it's really gotten me but it's
like
it's just like you're outside of your
own head back here
um and you just
you're just out of it like you're just
you're not where you want to be and then
that creates more anxiety and then it
just like it compounds
yeah you're hyper aware of of all these
these these negative things you're
ruminating on all these negative things
which now appear to be real but they're
really not
but you're making them feel real right
yeah but the circumstances i'm talking
about where
i was not in control of the environment
um
whereas like what you're talking about
is interesting to me because
you know in that convention space you're
complete control yeah
the anxiety still crept in um
you know exactly but i think for me it's
always like my whole life i'm anxious to
make people
you know like me happy with me i want to
make you feel like okay rosenbaum's
always going to make me laugh
he's going to the energy is going to be
good we're going to get through the day
it's going to be more fun with him
around and i i feel like i i
i want to make you uh enjoy yourself
well exactly but i'm saying i think
there's a there's enough well i think
i've never felt enjoyment with you
what i'm saying is that i think that i
always want i'm a people pleaser i want
to make everybody happy i want to like i
wanna
i always was like the fence the guy in
the middle that was i was watching the
bg's documentary which you should watch
you'll love it it just came out no i
just heard about this
it's very fantastic but maurice was the
middle gib he was mid
gib and there were rob and gibb and
barry gibb on his brothers
and and you know they fought because
they were the best singers in the band
you know
robin was the guy or barry was like like
i'm waiting for this moment to last
you know and he would get the high and
the other but but together they were
enormous but they used to fight i i want
to be
i want to be the leader i want to be the
leader and maurice was the guy in the
middle
and so i'm like no no no he loves you
it's your brother he
no no no no that's not what he meant so
i was always like that as a kid with my
family you know your sister's a god dang
no no no she's your daughter peacekeeper
peacekeeper and that
is exhausting i don't think you ever
wore you like i envy you because
in a lot of ways you uh i don't know if
you were innately born a leader i mean
look you you've you've got flaws you
like i know that you can be
short-tempered sometime you have you're
impatient like me
what what what you know and that's
and you're working on that jess is a
great wife because she also calls you
out on it and you're like oh
yeah she's very quite grounding yeah
yeah does she does she ever say like tom
cause like
obviously i've seen therapy i i know
every actor i think ever does she ever
say tom maybe you should see someone
yeah she has yes she has
and what did you do did you say so well
there's someone that her and i both
talked to not at the same time and it's
been very helpful and he actually
brought the bg's documentary
with a different point of he said it was
i should watch it it's interesting
because
there's this thing in psychology where
you can never be creative if you're
being
um you can never be in the creative mode
when you're in the survival mode
and he referenced the bg's documentary
because
as they grew to fame in the disco era
and that went out of fashion very
quickly apparently
they rose to fame it went up then they
were in survival mode and they
apparently i haven't seen it but
apparently they sort of regrouped
and they realized they could write this
music um
in a different style and because the
falsetto that they use
it was a male-dominated disco era and as
they came out of that
the falsetto was actually more of what
they wrote
lended more toward the female voice
and they wrote a lot of music for a lot
of dionne warwick barbra streisand yes
exactly but you just said something that
i think is incredibly valuable and i
haven't heard it on the podcast and
maybe
uh it's so simple but you said you can't
be creative when you're in survival mode
yeah yeah i this is something that's
been resonating with me in the last few
months since i've heard it and it's been
explained to me
and especially you know listen you can't
talk to anybody for more than five
seconds without the covet
thing right and it's hard and it's
different and we're gonna get through it
um but what it does it puts you in
survival mode
and what we have to strive for is to
remain in creative mode and you and i
you and i
you know we talk all all the time about
like hey what can we do how can we be
creative and you're very
self-motivating in that way of like what
can we do what can we create
because the flip side of that is despair
and
feeling sorry for yourself and or making
wrong decisions based
on maybe what is now but won't be in the
future
so i'm rambling a little bit no
i like this you can't be creative when
you're trying to survive
so from your therapy you know back to
that like he's
you're like hey you know i could be
impatient i can be this and like this so
what does he do kind of kind of talk
talk to you about where it's coming from
and
how you can uh what does he tell you to
do to help that
because it's an interesting thing it's a
guy that we
that we talk to he it's not necessarily
about it
it's hard to explain and i don't know if
this is gonna be worthwhile you know for
you and this podcast but
it's more about the idea of where things
might come from it's more of discussion
um and it's just about what do you think
about this we think about that and it
could be this
but he has really narrowed down the idea
for me which i touched on
earlier with you is like the mother is
very important and a lot of times
when whoever we are when we
go into the self-discovery realm
it's you know the more you know about
your mother the more you can understand
about yourself because there's a good
number of years there where you were
you were you were impressed certain
values and certain ideas and certain
energies
and certain um passions and
how you were treated before you ever had
a chance to walk or talk
and you know it's as an adult the idea
is you grow up and you
you you're able to acknowledge that and
make your own decisions and
treat your life your own way so um
you know i mean you're you're a very
well-rounded person as far as i'm
concerned
and you see those things i mean going
back to what like your mother looks for
you for guidance in a way and
yeah but like you know you say the
trickle-down thing
i'm curious as to what trickled down
from your mother or father but i'm also
curious like
you know um for me i
think i'm very good at making people
feel like i have my [ __ ] together and
i'm creative and i'm always confident
i'm always this
and what this podcast has done for me is
it's allowed me
to express insecurities and
vulnerabilities that i normally wouldn't
discuss with most people
and then also in a way it makes me feel
like
everything's okay like you know what you
can go do this and you could fail and
people are gonna still love you
you can go do this and you can take a
chance and it's gonna be okay you're not
it's almost like these little things
that if you talk about them enough
then they almost get dissolved in a way
they almost dissolve when you have
people out there listening going i get
that i get being you know
you know i'm just trying to survive well
i'm not at my best when i'm trying to
survive so
what am i trying to you just literally
use the word survive and
listen i'm not the all-knowing thing
about this but um
when you're trying to survive it's a
lonely
journey and what you're talking about
when i hear from you when i listen to
your podcast
is the joy that i get out of listening
is it makes me feel a little less alone
if that makes any sense because other
people are the same
and that's the survival creative thing i
mean i read this thing about kristen
bell the other day which i know has been
on your podcast
she's like listen you know i just got to
a point where i wanted to be
genuine and express these things and
she's found a way to
get closer to herself and to the people
around her by being genuine and exposing
vulnerabilities because we all have them
there's there's just this pretext of
like we're supposed to be perfect
because
you know if you're looking to media as
an example
well you're going to always be
disappointed because that's what media
is trying to do is just
show you the best or worst right
somebody who
i wanted to talk about today real quick
um i don't know if you've seen the math
mcconaughey book green lights
no i don't know him but i i read the
book and it's
you should have on your podcast because
he's amazing i'm gonna call him i'm
gonna call him
journals he's had for since he was i
don't know 20. is it called all right
all right all right
nobody says that a little bit but it's
called green lights okay
and it's about making sure there's green
lights yellow lights and red lights and
you try to create more green lights for
yourself
um but the idea of you're just trying to
like
create opportunities for yourself and
bring people in
as opposed to keeping people out but one
of the things when you talk about your
anxiety and the people that i've seen
speak to you is it makes me feel less
alone
it's and especially these days where
everybody feels isolated we all feel
isolated before
in our own heads and said so well you
know i think of you as someone who
again i i'm just not that guy
but when i feel like you know tom
doesn't need anything tom doesn't need
anyone he needs he has his wife and he
has his child
but before that tom just either you
didn't let anybody into that because you
are a private guy
and i appreciate you always to open up
whatever you want to open up and you
know i'm always uh
happy when you just talk to me but
ultimately
you know you hold a lot in i'm sure but
you go you know you're kind of like you
do something you go home you don't need
anybody you don't need to be around a
lot of people
and do you get lonely do you feel
sometimes lonely even though you have a
kid a child you ever feel like
i'm i'm still alone in a way sometimes i
think there's been times i think
like when we were doing smallville there
was a lot of loneliness because i didn't
know how to navigate that and maybe i
kind of kept everybody away because i
just
i wanted to be alone because one i
didn't have any time alone
during those years and your ex wasn't
that supportive not to bring her up
i don't know i mean like i don't i don't
know how you go further than
non-supportive whatever that word is i
noticed that i just always remember like
you know a woman or a man needs to they
just need to support each other
and i mean if you're in a relationship
you want support and if you're single i
mean like you are you have a
you have a great support system around
you with your friends and your family
but
support is very important um
but i listen i'm i mean i don't mind
being by myself i
mean everybody needs time to themselves
um as you know i just moved
and got some more space up in northern
california and
at least for an hour a day i go outside
and i'm up in the hills in the mountains
and by myself and that's
it's like a i don't see it as an act of
meditation but it probably
is it just gets me out yeah one thing um
but you know my my
glorious wife and my and my hilarious
son
definitely helped me not feeling like
lonely of course yeah
so that i mean i i
i only wish that you could find what i
have when you get
hard well you know by the way i know
congrats on the
the you know you got a kid another kid
on the way well
what you have another kid on the way i
no yeah dude i talked to jess i i
thought you
are you serious yes
inside of you is brought to you by
echelon guys you know i have all this
stuff in my house
i don't leave the house especially
during crazy times whacked out times
like this
seriously i get ryan i could just go
down on my rower i can go on my bike i'm
gonna go down on your rower i can go
down on my rower okay i could go
downstairs and i could hit the rower i
can go my stationary bike i could hit
the mirror which shows me to stretch
correctly
i could take a boxing course echelon's
affordable i love the service i had a
problem with something
it was my own damn fault i figured it
out but i called them and they had
someone call me back it was like a
saturday night
i don't know if they'll do that for you
maybe because i'm a celebrity but i'm
just saying
echelon really is uh no they are
fantastic and
they're offering the next generation of
connected fitness bikes
fitness mirrors rowing machines and
their echelon stride
smart treadmill no matter what your
favorite fitness
activity echelon gives you a fun and
challenging workout from the comfort of
your own
home the ex-7s is echelon's latest
state-of-the-art innovation that takes
cycling
to the very next level the ex-7s
connected bike is built with performance
flexibility and durability in mind
the ex-7s is the bike for competitors
at heart and unlike their competitors
which i've said echelon is affordable
for everyone and one membership just one
lets up to five family members all work
out at the same time and right now
you guys can try echelon fitness
equipment at home for 30 days
you're going to love it because i'm
telling you and i i've never had one
complaint from people saying oh you said
that and this sucked
i'm telling you this stuff's great and
it's cheaper so if you're looking to
exercise
and get your life in order for the new
year these are the guys man echelon
go to echelonfit.com inside of you
that's
e-c-h-e-l-o-n fit dot com
slash inside of you inside of you is
brought to you by
petsmart if you have a pet you gotta use
petsmart you know ryan how we have like
door dash or things and we get things
delivered to us
well doesn't your pet deserve the same
thing
yeah and the thing is you don't even
just have to say your pet you deserve it
because it's easier for you because they
don't pay for their own crap you paid
for it exactly
so why wouldn't you want to order
something and not have to get out of
your off your butt
and drive somewhere to pick it up you
can have it delivered or you go
there it's just a petsmart is freaking
smart and that's all i want to say about
that
from the beginning of the pandemic
petsmart has been an essential retailer
making sure you can get everything your
pet needs right when you need it
over 600 convenient locations and what i
like about petsmart stores ryan you know
what i like
clean yeah safe they follow protocol you
know and i think that's really important
disinfecting protocols face coverings or
masks
required for employees and pet parents i
think that's really great
stores and grooming salons offer digital
check-in
curbside drop-off and pickup and
contactless payment
petsmart now has responded to the
unprecedented demand for contactless
shopping by adding curbside pickup for
website or app orders and now
petsmart offers free same day delivery
powered by
doordash through january 31st 2021 so
you can get everything your
your pet needs don't forget free same
day delivery powered by doordash
offer expires january 31st get in on
that check out
petsmart.com for more details
that's petsmart.com for more details
petsmart.com
she told you yeah she told me you lied
bastard ah but you do you have another
one coming you
yeah little thompson he's the cutest
little you know there's nothing more
infuriating than when
beautiful people have beautiful children
i'm telling you
like we you and i facetime last week and
thompson started talking but and i was
like this is what happens
uh you know you're friends with kids
because i kept just putting thompson on
the facetime with you over and over
i know thank you same mentality level
it's good but i find myself being like
hey man i know i'm biased but this kid's
here but
you know what he is yes he's a good
cute funny kid he makes me laugh all the
time what trickled down
from your mom and dad because i i think
you uh
i want to know what you you think
trickle down good or bad um
as you know i'm i'm a little private so
i
wouldn't necessarily just like talk to
you as if i was talking to like
right right but but there there are
things um you can't help it a little bit
of
i think my work ethic definitely like
almost to a fault where um i have a
tendency to
want more information about like say a
project
more information than maybe people want
to give me before i agree
but that's because when i agree or i
signed a contract
i am like so in like
it's there's no out so that's a good
thing that trickled down then
it is but i've had to temper that a
little bit because people are like dude
you have to get the job before you ask
those questions i'm like well i don't
want the job until i know these
questions or blah blah blah
so i've had to like be a little more
savvy politically about how to get that
stuff
right um but i think you know there's a
good naturedness there's a midwesterness
that you and i
share and whatnot but there's also you
know my
you know i've come to realize and i i
don't mean this in a bad way or not but
i get to spend so much time with my
family and my son right now
based on the fact that i'm not on set
and the coveted shut things down
and like my parents never had that
opportunity my mother raised
four kids while my dad went to work like
every day all the time and you know i'd
see him on the weekends and to me that
was normal
now i'm looking back and there's a
little bit like oh
i maybe i was missing my dad a little
bit and i didn't realize it because it
was just normal
you know i see that now as i look at my
own son and where i want to be for him
because
when hopefully i do go back to work as
you know it's
three months six months a year of
limited access to your family you know
even when you do come home
from work it's you're exhausted and
you're you know
there's no like it's hard to juggle so
i'm really enjoying this time that i
have of just like
spending time with my family right now
because i think things are gonna really
pick up
oh yeah you know once everyone feels
safe enough to do so subconsciously you
resent your father
that's i'm kidding okay
you know the whole thing a couple months
ago the whole tom cruise thing about
when he
when he lost his loss is cool
and you know george clooney said
something where
he was like i don't have all the
information but maybe it's not the first
time that tom's had to deal with that
and tom's
argument is like hey guys we've been
allowed to shoot
under these certain circumstances but we
have to follow these rigid
protocols and if we don't we're out of
business and a lot of people following
our lead are gonna be in trouble
so you know that's what it's gonna be
going forward now do you have to yell at
people i don't know i wasn't there
but you know that kind of stuff is
is gonna continue yeah i hear that i
mean look you get a little bit
uncomfortable
on set some things happen there's this
you know i don't i didn't actually hear
tom cruise yell but like
i could never lose my [ __ ] on somebody
for that long as christian bale did i
mean
it would be more like dude shut the [ __ ]
up oh my god
carl i usually know all the guys names
so it's kind of a joking way like you
know i'd be like
what the jd dude
i could barely remember my lines and
you're [ __ ] eating like a [ __ ]
cow shut the [ __ ] up you know if that
got recorded people might go oh my god
he was a bit of a net no i'm kidding but
i'm not
and nobody sees russ or jd on the other
side of that laughing being like my bad
by the way you know our good buddy russ
from smallville
who i love dearly big bearded guy
lovable every morning russ
michael how are you i give him a big hug
he goes all right
and he just passed away and uh my shout
out you know he passed away a little
while ago but
my heart goes out to his family and i
cried when he died i just
he was just a family member to me i just
remember seeing him every day i saw
again
when you're on set for as long as we are
you you
they are family and uh and i know you
remember them and
you just as you get older people it's
just life it's just they start
dying you hear about it and there's
certain people that affect you and when
you're on on set as long as we were
you know like honestly like god forbid
something happened to natalie who was
our makeup artist forever
i i would lose my [ __ ] i you know well
and it's funny because as
i don't want to say analyze but as you
look at it there's certain people that
i think fit different roles for me like
russ was a very grounding
yeah he was a big guy and yet you know
but he was grounding like when you saw
russ
you felt safe like
he was gonna take care of you he was
gonna take care of whatever you need
you know that kind of thing and you know
when you saw natalie you were
you know maybe your depression lifted a
little bit
because of her light you know and ever
you know we had a really good in jd
who was our camera operator who just
kept everything fun
but like was like the best camera
operator in the world
oh you know yeah came on set and like
just did his job
just did his job and was friendly and he
i'd see him [ __ ] up the smoke machine
and just smoke everywhere and he's
wafting it everywhere the thing goes i
go russ what happened he goes well a
goddamn motor on this thing
like i don't know well he was in a funny
situation where
um his job was the smoke
everybody on set hated the smoke
everybody you were like you're not smoke
so
now he's like this is my job
like a rust do we have to have a smoke
here's not my call michael
i'm not my goal you know
he also got in charge at times in the
fortress of solitude for the
for the snow that would my jazz hands
would would trickle down and the
fortress you weren't in the fortress
that much but
and it was the same thing it was like do
we need this i'd look at ross and he'd
be like
it's my job there were times on that set
but do you remember the caves
yeah those are the worst dude the kid
you oh i just saw your face change you
look pissed
they had these caves on the small little
set where and you know tom you know you
were going to reminisce about this
it's like that it was not even smoke it
was like the dust and the [ __ ]
i remember having worked in the caves
before you ever saw them
and they they put like wood chips on the
ground too
so like the caves the smoke
it was like humid it didn't smell good
and then your
your feet slipped around as you walked
and i i have a vague memory of like
you walking in a set and being like
really
you've been in here this is what you've
been doing like in here
but it was exactly what lex would have
thought too so it was like perfect you
know you always tell these stories and
you know maybe people have heard them
before but uh
they always make me laugh when you know
for instance
i i didn't always know what was going on
and i kind of like thought
you know because i remember this thing
with christopher walken he says i don't
read scripts because you're gonna find
out what happens when you watch the
movie
and so we always played around with that
you read the scripts inside out but like
me i remember you tell the story about
me walking on set because there was a
character zod who was
part of the uh you know what tell the uh
yeah tell the zod store i love hearing
this well the zod story i mean that
didn't take place in the caves but
we were outside and
oh it still makes me laugh there is this
so there's two zod stories one is that
you'd come to me a week before
we started and you were like dude dude
because you had
you had you did this thing where you
would come to me
and maybe to other cast members and you
would want to run lines for
what was going to happen the next week
you wanted to get ahead of it because
you had a lot of lines i didn't have a
lot of lines
but i had a lot of hours that i was
there it was like oh yeah yeah
and you'd want to run lines sometimes
and i'd be like oh my god dude i can't
even think about next week i'm just
trying to get through today and we'd run
them and you'd already be off book and
you'd be completely prepared
and that was this the process um
and it ultimately helped me anyway
because then it got me thinking about
whatever but
um you can't do one time and you're like
dude dude
check this out they want me to play
another character and i was like
yeah i mean all right whatever yeah his
name's like zod or something
i'm like who's that and you're like i
don't know dude i'm like no i do this
we were like we couldn't have been less
informed as
for our characters and uh and you're
like yeah dude i'm playing lex in the
same episode you know what that means
and i'm like
uh no what it was i mean because they
got to play me twice
and i was like they gotta pay me twice
yeah i'm not sure it works that way
you're like [ __ ] yeah you're like
guess what people didn't even tell it
yeah
all of a sudden i thought you because it
was a big part i'm like
i'm playing this guy too so you
you're paying me twice like no you're
playing this character
lex becomes odd well that sucks
i gotta i remember you just laughing i
remember doing
one time this is what these [ __ ] on
smallville did they
had me dress up as the president and try
to make me learn
15 pages of dialogue to give a speech
which they
so i'm on there on the podium and i'm
like i'm directing that episode
right and i go where the uh i didn't
memorize it hold on hold on
let me interject interject let me tell
the story because it's much better from
my perspective
so it's me and it's glenn glenn winter
and if anybody knows anything about
smallville
or arrow or anything else you should
know who glenn winter is uh but
and and many other things so he's he's
deep peeing and i'm directing and
we set up this stage where
you know lex's president comes out and
looks across
everybody as the president does wearing
the glove the black glove the white suit
yep and you know we hadn't given much
thought to it because
you were never that person that we were
worried about being prepared or
unprepared
like we just it was never concerned that
you were unprepared like it never even
entered my mind ever
and so we come up for the blocking
and you walk out on the podium the
blocking is just like when you everybody
hits the remarks so you get the lights
right and then everybody kind of goes
away for five ten minutes
and then then you know the next stage
is we we roll the camera so you come up
for the blocking and i'm
and you're like i'm not going to run the
dialogue there's so much dialogue i'm
not gonna run it we're like okay
and you're only standing there so i'm
like glenn you good he's like yeah he's
lit good he's good all right
cool a couple of tweaks couple
adjustments you know and you're like how
much time till we shoot
glenn was like i know five minutes ten
minutes okay so you leave
so then you're like i don't want to do
rehearsal i just want to shoot and
you're like very like i don't know if
you had a flight to catch or whatever
but it was like it was this build up of
like you were ready and i'm like
wow all right man that's like 12 15
pages of dialogue and he just wants to
go right in and like
damn all right cool i wouldn't do that
so
you're like i don't want to do
rehearsals just roll cameras i'm going
to come out
so like fine so we're ready you're
behind the screen
and they go and so i'm like glenn you
got yeah so you go action and you
walk out of the podium i mean there's
150 people in the cast and everybody you
know
waiting for you to come out you walk up
to the podium and you get there and you
look around you're like
we're at the teleprompter
and we were like wait cut what
and you're like we're the teleprompters
we're like we don't have any
teleprompters
he's like there's 12 pages of dialogue
i'm the president united states i would
have a teleprompter where's the timeline
i'm not learning 12 pages of dialogue oh
my gosh
tom was like he's actually right a
president would read off a teleprompter
and i didn't learn the lines so what
happened we cut the scene right no no
what happened was in my recollection is
you're like give me 15
20 minutes and you went away and you
came back and you had it um
that's how i remember yeah i remember
but i remember it got cut the scene got
cut or something well yeah cause it
wasn't very good yeah it wasn't a very
good scene i should have memorized it
hey you know what one of those funny
things anyway
i got abandonment issues because you
move during this hulk
thing my friend sean spencer move my
friend john heater move
my move my friend chris dowling moved
everybody's moved
and i'm like [ __ ] like i i can't ride my
scooter up to your house anymore
i can't like you know you're like 10
hour whatever where the hell are you
you're far away
so it's now you live in this place
you're you're again you're you got this
little ranch
you just bought horses it sounds like
you're not abandoned
it's not it's not i know you sounds like
jealousy
maybe it's jealousy but you have two
horses now too you have these what are
they called
well they're miniature horses it's uh
diana and harry
well diane and harriet but they're
hannah harry and
you have enough space you have stables
yeah we basically
um you know this covet thing um
i don't know if you and i have talked
about this before but it kind of put a
lot of pressure on some friends
and myself where i always knew that l.a
wasn't going to be the end all be all
for me and and when this whole head it
kind of was just like what are we doing
here like
why don't we really think about the next
stage that we were
going to be looking for anyway so it
sort of moved everything up for us five
or ten years
so we found a ranch up in northern
california that
pretty much was better than even what we
were looking for
um and really just gave us a lot of
space for us as a family especially for
my son
and to build and grow and you know the
mentor horses are funny and
i mean they're hilarious um and it's
just
i i i feel very thankful
to to be in a sp in a place with so much
space because
living up the street from you we just
there wasn't enough space for us and in
los angeles you can't go anywhere anyway
yeah you know i mean you listen you're i
wouldn't call you a hermit but i mean
you spent a lot of time at your house
yeah but even when you want to leave now
there's nowhere to go
no i don't really leave the house much
it's true i
come up here i i'm gonna come up there
all right you know i told you i'm gonna
come up
i'm gonna come up i almost tried to
blackmail you and said i wouldn't come
on your podcast unless you did it live
here i should have
you know what i'm gonna do that next
time we're gonna do it next time hey
look uh
i saw the uh trailer for this movie this
tv show you did
uh called professionals oh yeah and uh
and i
saw it i was like it looked like the
production value was huge
and i remember you going to do this and
i and i see it and it's one of those
things where i've been on stuff that all
of a sudden they hold it for six months
and then nothing happens with it
then i've done stuff and all of a sudden
they do air like what's going on with it
do you even know what's happening with
it because it looked cool [ __ ] yeah it
was crazy we went down to
south africa for three months and we
shot and it was a it was a very uh
adventurous shoot um but a very exotic
thing you know for me it was it was
supposed to be a uh
like an a team slash oh since 11 sort of
idea
um it was all daylight it rained for
one hour and three months in
johannesburg that is all blue skies like
that's just the season there
which is the exact opposite of what
vancouver is
if you think about it but um it was a
very adventurous crazy dangerous shoot
yeah you got shot at right well i didn't
but one of our cars did
uh another cast member got carjacked and
and i listen i don't want to go and
say that johannesburg is is
i mean it's not a safe place but some of
the people we worked with who were from
johannesburg
it's just the norm for them but uh one
of the
one of the wardrobe people's uh
their car got shot with an ak-47 like
crosstalk all right
wait wait what day was this in the shoot
was this day three because day four i
would have been on a plane
no this was probably four weeks in but
every day i had
i had three security guards and they're
not just like security guards and suit
these guys are like military guys
we've got with machine guns and i had
three guys with me
at all times did you feel safe with them
i mean i felt safe with them uh
i would leave the hotel and i would get
into an armored vehicle
that had a trail vehicle that was
armored there were two guys with me and
one guy in the back one and the idea
they told me is
i go what if we get pulled over or what
if we get an
accident because i was like curious
about this this lifestyle and how they
handle it yeah
and they're like basically if we get an
accident
one of us would put you in the trail car
and they would take you to the hospital
we're not waiting for the ambulance like
it was like
because you don't know if you're getting
carjacked you know it was very
i mean it sounds like a movie on its own
it was scary and the idea was for
jessica and thompson to come
down there once i got settled and it
really was just like
uh it wasn't safe so i you know they
didn't come down but you're right the
behind the scenes would have been
a little even more exciting and brennan
fraser
who's you know the co-star he got
carjacked
uh while we were down there yeah they
just
and they just wanted a cell phone
nothing else was he nervous was he
um he was a little shaken up the next
day as we talked about it
i think what happened you know you go to
these places
and you you know you're excited and
you're filming and you know oh you're
always looking for the best of
everything
and when something like that happens it
really kind of
wakes you up to like oh wait a second
i'm
this is it sounds ridiculous but like
this is real
so did you really feel like what
percentage of you every day on set was
thinking
i i could this i could be in trouble
here were you always was it always in
the back your head
um i felt i was safe on set i was safe
when i like once i left the hotel room
with those guys
with with the three-armed security you
know
uh like ex-military guys um
i mean i was safe um
but on the weekends like the two days
that you'd have off you don't leave the
hotel
and if you do you have to call and the
three guys show up and they go with you
what were their names i don't i don't
remember their excitement
johann and they and they rotate out but
they're
they're also the same guys who go into
the safari
or into the um reserves and protect
rhinos
real men is the word they're real men
real
live or die situations for sure like you
and i like to joke around a lot there's
some things they didn't
want to joke around about like i'm like
you know what like i'd be driving home
like i don't know friday night at nine
o'clock whatever and
they're like do you have any plans for
the weekend because they want to know if
they need to be there to go with me and
i'm like
no i think i'm just gonna go for a jog
you know at night at like 2 a.m
see how far i can go and they were like
don't joke about that like
that's not funny what
i just love watching your face tell the
story you're almost reminiscing and
going oh
did you how much did you miss like
honestly were you
like heartbroken that you missed
thompson and jess that much
yeah it was there were a couple days
where they were much tougher i mean
every day i obviously missed them but
there were a couple days
really tough um you know thompson was
really small
um so i kind of convinced myself that
you know he didn't know i wasn't there
and what he really needed was his mom
but you know his mom my wife she you
know
obviously you know we just tried we did
the best we could and she's a champ
and she she's on board she's a real dog
with like understanding that
it was the job and stuff um but
ultimately
we were able to she was able to get out
to new york and be with my sister and
her husband and their family and my
parents and that helped out a lot
you know just because yeah you know
otherwise she was just alone
a new mom with a little baby and so
she's a real champ through that um
but yeah i don't i don't want to do that
again
inside of you is brought to you by geico
what would you do without geico
well you'd be uninsured that would suck
yeah it would suck i know
friends that are uninsured but if you're
gonna get an insurance policy you want
something that everybody knows
that you know you're aware of it and
certainly geico is that
and they not only provide uh insurance
for maybe
one thing but insurance for many things
it's called a bundle
perhaps well instead of getting you know
uh just homeowners insurance with a
company and then oh then i have to get
an auto insurance with it
why wouldn't you just go to geico
building policies with geico geico
makes it easy to bundle your homeowners
or renters insurance along with your
auto policy
and it's a good thing because you
already have so much to do around your
home
just go to geico.com get a quote
see how much you could save it's geico
easy
visit geico.com today that's geico.com
inside of you is brought to you by met
pro
ryan do you want to improve your health
sure do you don't know where to start do
you nah
i had a feeling you'd say that there's
thousands of health strategies available
now the problem is when you see all
these things what do you i'm like a guy
in a uh ice cream store i want ice i
want chocolate or vanilla but there's
strawberry
shortcake chocolate trail mix it's too
much
and i don't know what to do so
identifying which way to go which one
works for you or your body is it's
difficult it is
according to metpro the key to seeing
results
get this the key to seeing results is
to master your metabolism
at medpro your metabolism isn't some
mystery it's a data point armed with
hard science met pro
is your health concierge delivering
one-on-one coaching
and personalized nutrition and fitness
regimens it's not just about weight loss
med pros coaches provide busy
professionals athletes weekend warriors
and everyone in between
with the support and education they need
to live a healthier life and god knows
i need that through their signature
concierge coaching this evaluation-based
approach has allowed poli and his highly
respected team to transform
thousands of lives from olympic athletes
and nfl mvps to celebrities and the most
influential business leaders in the
world backed by data
and driven by strategy metpro's team of
industry leading experts are
challenging generalized health guidance
by teaching people
how to optimally manage their weight and
achieve their associated performance
goals
and recently met pro has launched a new
tool that allows individuals to
experience the same science and tailored
strategy
that their experts use folks if you're
looking for a high touch experience
working with a metabolic expert or if
you want access to the tools their
industry leading coaches use
visit met pro dot co
slash inside to take their assessment
and speak with their team to learn which
option is best
for you remember visit met pro
m-e-t-p-r-o dot c-o
slash inside not com dot co
met pro dot co slash inside
inside of you is brought to you by the
apology line
wondering's new true crime podcast the
begins with alan bridge posting flyers
around new york city
asking people to anonymously apologize
for their crimes
not to god not to the police but to his
answering machine
within hours the calls start coming in
people
apologizing for stealing infidelity
lying
and even murder allen got dozens of
calls from people claiming to be
murderers
but one stood out richie
he was deliberate measured and his calls
would leave
thousands wondering if he really was the
serial killer he claimed to be
that is until richie offered to provide
proof
of his crimes unable to just listen
anymore
alan knew he had to try and stop him
if you're listening to the audio version
of this show stick around to the end to
hear a preview
of the apology line or you can listen
right now
on apple podcasts you know we were
talking a little bit about conventions
earlier and
uh you know since you started going
and uh i know you say oh yeah well i got
you going and and i do take credit for
that
but i i i do but i also i'm
so happy you're doing them because
together
it's it's really fun it's really fun and
people like seeing us together and
you know when this ends we've got some
big conventions planned and
we do this thing called smallville
nights guys i don't know if you've heard
of it but it's like
you know it's it's behind the scenes
it's tickets late night you know after
the convention is over
and tom and i kind of walk through
the walk the uh people who are there the
guests sort of
you know our time in smallville in a
short way and then we start to read
scenes but we
we do in a special way you know no one
can film it no one can it's just an
intimate evening with us kind of like an
improv night in a way
and people read scenes with us and some
guy gets a bald cap and you know and
and so we're going and it's just such a
fun like we were both kind of like is
this going to be fun
and once we did it we do it for like an
hour and a half
i mean the way the way i mean i i
chuckle just thinking about it because
and we all like the reason we don't
allow cameras or video tips is because
it allows you and i to really let loose
especially me
right that it's really important for me
because i have a tendency to be a little
wary but um
i don't know about you but like there's
maybe
three times a year that i laugh
so hard that i can't breathe but every
time we do small nights i i
that happens like multiple times like
you and i laugh like yeah
we can't talk it's just me with a lana
wig and hair in my face and like reading
that scene and small from the pilot and
then
i won't tell you everything that goes on
in there but if you guys ever have a
chance and you're a small little fan or
whatever
you just want to come out and have a
good time the smallville nights if you
see any us at a convention we're we're
actually going to
la mole well tom you're going to la
malay i wasn't invited but i'm still
going to go
yeah in mexico well you invited me so
i'll be in august but that's going to be
that's going to be
probably our biggest ever i think we
have access to a whole lot like
convention space oh yeah i think it's
gonna be like a thousand people
we'd like to do a big one and uh you
know hopefully i'll go it looks like
i'll
i'll go we're trying to work that out
but uh tom and kristen will be there and
we'll we'll do a small nights in mexico
and i'll tell you when i was there was
right at the beginning of the company
i'll never forget where i was
at the beginning of the pandemic and
that was me asking to fly home a day
early
to get back to la because they were
gonna close stuff in the airports and
whatever
yep me and dolph lundgren flew back and
that was it we had to go back
and i remember but the people in mexico
even though we couldn't
like touch them at that point it was
just the beginning we couldn't hug and
it was hard for us because we're like we
like hey give a hug
uh they were so amazing there uh
i just love the country i love the
people and uh i
i would be happy as [ __ ] to go back yeah
i mean they're all the conventions are
fun i'm getting iran but like that was
such a big welcome like it was
oh man it felt so good and it was scary
because
everybody knew ever it was just the
it was like literally if it was the
weekend after
it wouldn't have happened because of
kobe oh yeah like literally
if it had been one week later it
wouldn't happen and thankfully
i don't know anyone who got sick there
so that was really cool all right this
is [ __ ] talking uh these are patrons of
mine
they ask questions if you if you want to
join patreon i always message you right
when you join and it's a great fun group
it's patreon.com
inside and uh it's brought to you by
i'm just kidding michelle k i would love
to know if there are any good pranks tom
ever pulled on the small boat cast or it
pulled on him
uh now can you think of one that you
haven't told i literally
i just looked at the window i'm like
what have i not told
i mean we would always
like be we like poking at each other but
not ever at the
sake of of performance i mean
there's the one well we did have you
dress up in the green screen
uh skin tight leotard once oh god i was
so pissed i was
hanging like up there in this green
leotard and a green screen blending in
with the wall and you're like oh just a
little more
can you make a face like this oh i'm
like why would i do that
well and i'm doing all these stupid
things and they're just laughing their
ass out but on the camera i could have
been home
two hours ago and they were just [ __ ]
with me the uh
i think i think it was you one time i
had a try my trailer
again cause glenn was in on the jokes
yeah but i had a big trailer you know
whatever and i thought it was you who
one day i walk and the
the a.d goes oh michael know your
trailer's over here
and i go uh where and it was like this
three banger
so three three rooms in a row like
the size of like a small [ __ ]
and i go where he's like oh
that's your trailer today i'm like why
he's like i don't i don't know they just
that's your trailer i'm like
what the [ __ ] and i wanted to i went
upstairs to the production office i go
bob and he did he couldn't
even get one line out instead of going
yeah he immediately started laughing he
goes
i go you [ __ ] because i'm sorry i
couldn't even keep up we're going to
try to keep that joke going for a while
i mean it was the smallest trailer ever
i mean i had my little gym in there and
i was trying to i mean this
anyway i thought it was you i thought we
had it wasn't it wasn't with you but we
had this uh we had this new
brand new ad guy and if you guys don't
know ads i
it's basically the person who's the
least
has the least experience ever they're
the ones
that are that are given the
responsibility to knock on the
the actors trailer and say we're ready
and then follow them or lead them to set
third a ds are tads they're called teds
yeah
yeah dad and we had this guy it was his
i think it was his second day and i
don't think you were part of this but me
and steve oben
the wardrobe guy i'm like steve give me
a radio and
by the way you never give you never give
an actor a radio like that's just
oh dude we'll get fired if you give you
that radio because actors are not
responsible
yeah because i'm the one hey tom i'm the
[ __ ] ghost uh everybody's gonna take
a two-hour lunch today
so enjoy that i'm the actor guy i'm an
[ __ ] go ahead right and then
everybody goes who gave him the radio
and then that person gets fired great so
i said so i said to stephen come on give
me give me a raider he goes
i'm not going to give you my radio but
if you took it off my belt
then i couldn't do anything about it oh
yeah i was like
all right sorry take it off his belt i
think it was maybe it was
jimmy but i was anyway i'm like uh jimmy
come in
and he's like uh jimmy here like uh
jimmy uh
can you meet tom only outside of his
trailer yep on the way
to me there uh jimmy are you outside
tom's trailer yep i'm right here
uh saying that you're not there
and we're looking like from like you
know you're just [ __ ] with this poor
guy
and he's standing outside the trailer
and we're like uh tom's on his cell
phone saying that he's outside of his
trailer and he doesn't see you
he's he's trying to go home and this
poor kid is go like his physical
his physicality is like just [ __ ]
i'm in front of his trailer and he's
losing his mind
oh my god and then finally like
it ended up being like 15 people
stepping out laughing and the kid was
like
but it was also sort of like a welcome
to that it's funny as long as he doesn't
get fired
all right here we go rapid fire leanne p
what is something that people don't know
about
rosie liam what do you not know about me
or they don't know people don't know
about me i don't know i mean i think
people know a lot of stuff about you
um i think you
well this isn't very rapid fire go ahead
give it give it shoot it
[Music]
i don't i i don't know there's such
there's there's like an adventurous
spirit about you
that i don't think you follow enough
out physically out in the world like i
think you want to travel
and i think you want to see the world
like
but i don't see you like doing it
there's like a fear
isn't there for some reason you don't
like go on vacations like you don't like
go out and do things for yourself
you know what it is i bet it has
something do you ever see that
commercial where these this couple
they go to a castle and the guy's got
explosive diarrhea and and the the tour
guide or whatever is like
this castle once had 28 bathrooms
and the guy's like if it only had one
now
and i'm thinking i'm gonna be
uncomfortable uh you know yeah i gotta
wake up early to go look at [ __ ] i wanna
sleep i'm gonna be a bummer for the
other person
i just all these things come it's always
fear with me you're right you [ __ ]
know me
sorry for the f-bomb dave p rapid fire
do you feel closure on your smallville
character after the return of the
infinite earth's crossover
i felt closure on my character when we
finished smallville i thought the
infinite opportunity was was just icing
on the cake
good answer nico p does it still irk you
when people refer to you as
superman instead of clark kent it used
to not so much anymore
hmm jack slater my way poor me yeah for
you
who's superman now i'm like i've been
called worse that's sort of my comeback
oh yeah you have been jack s if you
didn't become an actor
what do you think you'd be doing let me
see if i can guess this if you didn't
become an actor
i i just part of me wanted to say
teacher but uh you know i don't know
nah i think i would be like a force i'd
be like in the forest fire service or
something like
something like this yeah and then you
get cast like who's that firefighter at
that
let's let's get him as a ruler by the
way like that that's the funny thing
like
imagine if like i never got cast as like
a force fight like that all i
wanted in life was to be a forceful
fighter and i can't even get that role
marissa anne i loved your portrayal
by the way congratulations marissa just
say congratulations marissa
congratulations she's graduating she's
awesome i loved your portrayal of kane
on lucifer
what were some of your favorite moments
working on the show with the cast
um well all of them actually but
it was really fun when i got to work
with tom and lauren
together because their back and forth
was so great and they were so welcoming
to allow me to be a part of it um they
were just they're they're like
they're extremely prepared um but at the
same time they want to have
fun with what they're doing and get it
done at the same time which
reminded me of kind of what we did in a
way of smallville
um but what a warm cast i mean uh
i've never i had never really been on a
show
where i was like the guy who was gonna
be there every couple episodes
and they were just like hey man what's
up you know like let's go do you have
their phone numbers do you talk to them
ever yeah lauren and uh my wife have
become great friends
um and then tom's a great dude and he's
always there
um yeah they're just so you could get
them on the show probably you could
probably spread the word
right oh i would reach out for sure if
you if you you'd have to ask
well all the patrons and listeners have
been going lucifer
lucifer get those actors on they're all
dying for those guys
i'd be happy to reach out oh well they
reach out and touch claudia newman
you and lauren would get along great
especially well tell her that that'd be
awesome claudine in what has been your
proudest moment as a
father so far i mean every second
every second especially when he runs and
puts his arms out and says dada
um it's every second i mean i was
thinking the other day that we were
doing
we were gonna do this podcast and like
you don't know until
you have a child and people who have
children know this and someone like you
who doesn't
has to listen to people say this but you
know
it's it's it's it's
there's nothing like it that's all you
can say ryan do you want to be a father
yeah i do tom what would you give advice
to ryan or anybody out there about being
a father what's the one thing you gotta
let go or one thing you just
you really need to know now that you're
a father in the moment well there's a
there's a funny thing where
when we realized that we you know we
were pregnant and one of my good friends
said
and i was like why are you laughing and
he's like it's not about you anymore and
i was like
yeah i know that like i know it's not
about me
but then when the baby arrives it still
took a couple months for me to
like there's a whole another phase of
like oh
i see it like nothing is about me
anymore
like that like you're a part of it but
it's a whole nother like thing in your
in your body that you feel
but it's the most rewarding thing you
can ever do in the same
in the same breath you know i will say
this and i i have no
resentment or regrets or you know life
is life
you know deals the cards and you take
them and
and you know you could respond or react
how you want you could blame you could
do this
i love my mother i love my father i've
talked about that but
i think that was a problem my mom got
pregnant so early and she was so young
and she hadn't got to do oh uh she
hadn't she she didn't do the things she
wanted to do right away
and i think that she even though she
loved us and did the best
she could so i don't blame her she she
still wanted to be the center of
attention
and that i think that that affected us
greatly or it
certainly affected us a lot because you
have to let go of that you have to
as a father if i ever have a just child
i have to be
you have to be like you cannot be
selfish the kid comes first
period here well there's a term called a
wonderful burden
that that that could have been the case
and i think parents
like that could happen to anybody where
like you have a child and it's
it could be a wonderful burden you know
like because of your situation
or you know maybe your mom was juggling
so many things at that time
you know i mean listen this is like just
kidding
you go down this road forever but um but
i but i think that's
yeah i mean you're my from your stories
you tell me i mean
your mom likes to be yeah yeah well look
and so do i so i get that it trickle
down i have to be the center of
attention but i'm saying
you know what i'm saying [ __ ] it kelly
kell
asked two questions and we're done buddy
you're out of it kelly yes
after 20 years of bromance with michael
have you ever had a fight
remember that there was just that one
time where i got mad but you were just
joking when i was directing an episode
oh but that's not a fight yeah that was
just you [ __ ] with me
no we don't really fight we so we know
the thing is is like sometimes he'll
tell me he's like dude
blah blah blah this is what has to get
done oh i'll go dude
just remember i guess ah you're right
let's go we do that
you know there's very few people in my
life i don't know about you that i have
the relationship with you where i just
i don't have to question your motives no
like i really i've never had to question
them and i don't know how we ever
really established that we just like it
i can't imagine like we've been at
conventions where like we're both going
in different directions and one needs
something it's like okay let's go
that's it it's like michael jordan
scotty pippen and i don't know who's who
but it's just like
i'm in like we already know like we're
teammates like
that's it we're friends yeah i agree 100
you know and
i have to say it's like i wouldn't say
you know i have i have close friends but
you know if someone needs me or when you
know i remember when you went to the
hospital
i [ __ ] i didn't think about should i
go it was just a certain people i'm like
i'm going to the hospital right now
right right you know what i mean there's
like that's how it's going to be and
that was a while ago so don't think he
just went to the [ __ ] hospital
what happened what happened little lisa
last one what's on your bucket list for
i mean i want to continue uh
growing my family but i want to get back
to work man like it's in a situation
where i feel like
where everyone's safe i want to work um
i'm i'm reading a lot of scripts
there's i have a lot of opportunities
out there that
more than i probably ever had before
it's just a matter of figuring out which
one is a safe environment a safe place
because we're all trying to do that in
our own lives as well can we try to do
something together i know we've talked
about it
we could do something just creatively
and not worry about whether it's a huge
success we could just do it to have fun
and if it's successful great
i think we should definitely there's
certain people in my life where i'm like
i just want to do something with them
well i mean
i think we briefly talked about this a
couple months ago but
you know let's come on up here where i
am where we can just shoot on my
property and we can climb mountains and
like do something fun
exactly like you know i don't i don't
think you need a permit to film on your
own property
maybe insurance by the way jordan jonas
the winner of season
alone season six remember he's a buddy
now and he's going to take us because he
won he knows how to survival skill so
you're going to go with me
padalecki's going to go chris daughtry
name dropping
and a couple of my friends who are just
been my friends for life who are not in
the industry
like lally and and maybe my friend
ballard and uh
you think my guess is jared carrying
lally up the mountain or something he'll
carry me i'm i'm telling you i'm i'm so
scared but
after this you're gonna be like
rosenbaum is just such an idiot i always
have this fear that i'm just gonna like
you guys are lighting fires and i'm like
sneaking in a lighter
and like you know and like you guys are
frying fish and i've got like
fish sticks from like more you know
gordon's fish sticks
and like i can't do anything and i'm
just oh that's why we have to do it
that's why we have to do it survival
remember you can't be creative if
you're in survival mode guys in creative
mode if you're in survival mode that's
that's my that's i hope i mean it's just
something to
when you think about it you can feel it
um
and you can like i don't know what i'm
even when i feel like i'm in survival
mode i'm i'm like even like
how can i be creative in my survival
mode somehow or how can i just
step back for a second and look at
options because in survival mode you
have a tendency to get
you know narrow-minded and and lose
foresight but
if you have the ability to just kind of
step back for a second i mean you're
really good at this i've seen you do
this and
um just sort of seeing the big picture
yeah
well dude look man i love you like a
brother and you've always been so
supportive man you wear my left and
laurel hat you listen to the album i
remember going oh my god i sold 20
things
the band we saw and i'm like oh it's all
from welling wellingborough
yeah i love those sets inside of you
online store well i will send you more
stuff man i always send you [ __ ] yeah
you know what i really love is when you
ride up to
well what used to be my house in those
scooters as badass scooters you have
um there's like the fat ones the fats
bad scooters yeah
yeah those are dope well maybe i could
talk to the guys about getting you one
maybe if you make a video
off-road tires and like make sure they
can
you know the suspension can carry me
video
yeah they are badass i love them they
they designed one of them my one of my
favorite movies the warriors the old
gang movie so they decked it out
warriors they did an inside of you one
for the podcast those guys are great
yeah
yeah drew and peter they take care of us
and in fact
you know i i work you know i do stuff
with the ronald mcdonald house and my
buddy um preston
they go hey can we give preston a
scooter i'm like yeah
they're just i mean they're just good
dudes and it's a good company fat
scooters man
i love those guys there and yeah we'll
get you one but hey guys
uh this is tom welling
dude you're awesome that was incredible
all right thanks for
having me on thanks thanks
version all right later buddy i love you
man
i love a guy he's a brother to me
welling's a brother always be a brother
um you know i always appreciate tom
coming back to the show and uh
he wears his left on laurel hat and his
inside of you hat i'm not with leftover
i'll have to wear a sunspin hat now
that's true but same thing with uh
stephen amell always wears the inside of
you hat and supported the band and um
i it's just nice people don't have to do
that and they do it and you know they do
it because either the hat fits really
nicely and looks really good on them or
they
want to support me or both or they
couldn't find another hat
thanks to everybody again for listening
and all my patrons i like the video
thing we did patrons so i'm going to do
that again where you guys ask questions
on video and i respond to them on video
it's a little thing guys inside of me
when you're a patron if you go to
patreon p-a-t-r-e-o-n dot com slash
inside of you
you join you support the podcast and
there's tears and there's lots of fun
and uh i might even do an another uh
youtube live with just the patrons this
weekend
so i'll let you guys know and don't
forget the inside of you online store
everything's 15 off with the code happy
new year
will you remind me ryan you didn't
remind me last time happy new year 21.
yeah i mean after the show yeah i didn't
need to be reminded
uh thank you please write a review go to
go to apple podcast write the review
um tell them you love it whatever you
want to do and thanks what westwood one
thank you ryan
of course for always giving badass
episodes thanks bryce for being
my uh right-hand man when it comes to
doing social and everything really helps
me out
and uh thank you thank you uh
to my grandmother who unconditionally
loves me and tells me every day
and uh it certainly means a lot by the
way uh write me and
tell me what you think of having my
grandma blanche in the podcast would
anybody watch
i'm gonna do it but would you like to
see her she's a sweet sweet woman and it
will just
uh make your heart feel nice and gooey
let's read the patrons want to do that
sure here we go these are all uh lovely
people and i know
uh just about all of them i know all of
them and that's what's great about
patreon you get to know people
nancy d thanks for the pillows leah s
thanks for the pillows trisha f
sarah v little lisa yukiko jill e
brian h lauren g
nico robin s jerry wood emily k
we got robert eye we got jason dabala
stephen j
kristen k not to be confused with
kristin krook amelia o allison
l jess j lucas m raj c
joshua d emily s cj p that's correct
samantha
m gosh you're good i wouldn't get these
yeah i would jennifer n
jackie p stacy l carly h jennifer s
janelle b
carrie b ashley k kimberly e crystal h
mike e marissa n danielle p jack uh s
yes jackass jack slater i love my jack
mira ramirez that's right beth b
santiago
and n m m good close sarah f chad w
leanne p correct row v wade
roshan roshenar russian rey hey maya p
maddie s tiffany i kendrick f ashley e
shannon d matt w belinda n kevin v
james r chris h anusha w
h gabby m amy c dave h samantha s
spider-man chase sheila g ray h
alyssa c tab of the t misha h deb a tom
and natalie six two two not to be
confused with that only six two three
suzanne b henry s kdf liliana a michelle
k
hannah b michelle s talia m lucas h
john s andrew t christy s claire m liz
j laura l you know which one we're
missing yuki maybe
no we got you kiko but i think uh maybe
someone left the patron could break my
heart oh no
tabitha 272 not to be confused with
traveling
well tabitha thank you for all your
support if you're not here with us i
just would like to give a special shout
out to you
um and the winners of the last stage it
we got ray ray i love you it was so
great talking to you in australia
um gracie i love you and thanks for
supporting uh
we we do these stages folks and they uh
you win prizes and there's zooms and
uh gracie won the early show and ray
won ray harada ray harada
won the other show great prizes and new
sunspin pictures and
it means a lot to me that you guys keep
coming i want to do these shows forever
i almost want to just
do the it's weird i kind of want to just
do the podcast and patreon and
do my music and stage it's and it'd be
nice i mean it's a blessing to be able
to do all these things
i love you guys thank you for allowing
me inside of you from my house in
undisclosed location yeah in the hills
uh
ryan thank you thank you let's wave
goodbye bye see you guys thank you